Warner Brothers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah thank you thank you now there's no
reason to stand so I'm glad you did
and it's too late this is an important
night and for a night this important
what's face that I need to dress the
parts God looking good and I'm feeling
good the precious audience II award
there's no award like it look at that
that was made that was made a nun in
under two minutes no care was taken in
its construction of a naked man with no
genitals sitting in a wooden chair let's
get into what our first audience award
is for the best impression of a
celebrity and the audience he goes to
the person in seat 5d for the impression
of Mandy Moore
[Music]
the next audience he wore tell super
best impression of his celebrity and the
audience he goes to the person is
heat-16
e for their impression of The Soup Nazi
from Seinfeld
a little too good
yeah the next audience he goes to the
person in seat 12l for their impression
of the eyeglasses emoji
[Music]
he's gonna wait for me in the parking
lot after the show yeah I don't think he
like that now he's coming after me he's
gonna shove this thing okay next up
tonight's foreign audience e goes to the
audience member in seat Z these are show
it getting miss on he's me buddy
this next audience he is for the most
loyal Conan fan he's been to every show
since we came to TBS almost 10 years ago
and the award goes to the fan and seat
16 be very good boy yeah
our final audience T of the night goes
to the audience member named Nancy who
has just now been selected to be the
next contestant on The Price is Right
[Applause]
hold on no no you don't understand that
the price is right it tapes it CBS
Studios that's across town you got to go
across town
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Nancy Nancy where's Nancy
[Applause]
you